not long after enlisting in the indian
armed forces
khali was disappointed to learn that
women were not allowed to serve in
combat units
this led to establishing a private
security company that would operate
within india's borders
later on she would broaden her reach and
founded the pmc
knighthaven that would operate across
the globe
in late 2020 kylie traveled to bangkok
thailand
and approached aruni with an offer to
join nighthaven
aruni accepted kylie's offer due to the
prospect of gaining cutting-edge
prosthetics
as well as donating her pay to charities
in 2019 six invited nighthaven to join
team rainbow
to bring their skills and expertise in
assisting in the fight against terrorism
on a global scale because of this
agreement later on
more nighthaven operators were added to
the rainbow roster
one of these operators was named rooney
my gate stands like a star in the
darkness
a burning light that keeps enemies at
bay
can you take the heat
[Music]
alpha tawan roon code named aruni is a
defending operator in team rainbow
aruni was born in tathreya the most
northeastern district
of sakhal province in eastern thailand
growing up along the thai cambodian
border posed a significant hazard
as these areas had once been the
battlefields of warring factions
and were plagued with unexploded
landmines
sadly children were at particular risk
of injury and death from landmines
because of their small size unfamiliar
shape and colours can make them look
like toys
their deadly attraction for children
whose innate curiosity
and need for play often lure them
directly into harm's way
children are more likely to be unaware
of the dangers of playing or traversing
in hazardous areas
because of their desire to explore and
tragically when aruni was just a small
child she too lost her little sister to
an unexploded landmine
unaware of imminent danger her sister
picked up the unusual looking object
and proceeded to play with it her small
frame was decimated by the blast
and she died shortly thereafter
[Applause]
devastated by her death and in the way
she had died as a rooney got older she
decided she wanted to help those
emotionally and physically injured by
landmines
not long after leaving high school aruni
attended university where she obtained
a bachelor of arts economics and a
master of law
she decided the time had come to choose
a path in life and armed with her
bachelor's degree
she started pursuing a career as a
private investigator
she knew one of the most vital resources
to have under one's belt as reliable
sources
these people are vital in assisting in
investigations
she knew she had to start the process
right from the beginning as it takes a
while to develop good sources
she talked to people and socialized in
many different settings
her goal was always to see if any of
these individuals could potentially
provide her with invaluable information
that might be helpful to cases in the
future and the ones that did
she developed great ties with she also
needed to be tech savvy
as the nature of crime and fraudulent
activities is ever-changing
as an aspiring private investigator she
decided to take a few specialized
courses
that focused on specific areas of
investigation and interrogation
along with undergoing training to help
with mastering defense techniques
and learn how to use weapons she also
obtained a firearms license
it was during her time as a private
detective that she was successful
in discovering a bomb plot in bangkok
which as a result
brought her skills to the attention of
the royal thai police
this predominantly male-dominated law
enforcement agency
eventually grew to grudgingly respect
her talents the way in which she could
efficiently piece together so many
different details
and seemingly unrelated events and how
exceptional she was at joining up the
dots in relation to a number of criminal
syndicates
in open investigations she is a real
cerebral force
always processing something in her head
and making connections that aren't
obvious to others
not surprisingly because of this she
became very well known
in the good circles and the bad and
faced an increase in hostility towards
her by a number of these gangs
[Applause]
eventually the royal thai police offered
her a position working as a detective
in their crime suppression division
during this time she successfully
located
and foiled no less than four bomb plots
along with dismantling
a large human trafficking ring her
natural ability to trace various
shipments of explosive materials
and connect them to the bad guys was
highly commended by her superiors
[Applause]
she was at the pinnacle of her career
and it looked like she was on her way to
being the top dog
however just as everything was seemingly
coming together for her
tragedy struck and her police career
ended abruptly when she was nearly
killed during an operation in bangkok
aruni had been tasked with working
alongside the fbi's hazardous materials
response unit
and it was at this time she met jordan
trace thermite
although most of the details regarding
the operation in bangkok are still
largely classified
a number of elements have been released
it appears as though aruni and thermite
were in the process of tracking down a
large criminal weapons scheme
stumbled across a bomb they knew they
had to get this bomb
as far away as possible from innocent
civilians and out of the city
so they quickly took action with the
assistance of a pickup truck
they began swiftly transporting the bomb
rapidly through the streets of bangkok
unfortunately thermite decided this
would be one of those times he would
plow on a head
and attempted to defuse the bomb while
aruni drove the vehicle
thermite crouched on the tray of the ute
with the bomb and all of its wires
exposed in front of him
the back window of the pickup had been
broken and they communicated through the
gap to each other throughout the journey
oftentimes thermite can get locked onto
an idea
and even though he's more than capable
of being a conscious thinker he's been
known to be quite bull-headed at times
regardless of whether or not this was
one of those times unfortunately his
attempts at dismantling the bomb
paired with the sudden head-on impact
with another vehicle spelled disaster
on impact thermite was immediately
thrown from the back of the pickup
and the detonation of the bomb occurred
simultaneously
he threw his arms in front of his face
to protect himself from the heat
flames and flying shrapnel the explosion
tore through the truck
the impact causing the device to fly
through the back window
there only moments earlier arunian
thermite had been conversing
through the result was devastating
a rooney trapped in the front had no
chance of escaping the impact zone
and was engulfed in flames the shards of
shrapnel tore through a delicate tissues
severing a number of vital muscles and
tendons along her left side
thermite's injuries seemed to pale in
comparison to hers but still
the flames had left their mark and it
was permanently branded with a number of
burns
to its upper extremities the incident
costa rooney greatly
and as a result she lost both her left
leg and left arm
and nearly her life although thermite
eventually made a full recovery from his
injuries
he felt partly responsible for the
accident and what had happened to a
rooney for quite some time
he felt he had let her down they were
supposed to have each other's backs
and at one point he was fearful she
wouldn't survive
and his feelings of guilt were only
helped by the fact that on a number of
times he tried to reach out to her
her replies had often been brief in
terse
in order to focus on her rehabilitation
aruni decided to completely withdraw
from her position
at the royal thai police force she
returned to work as a private
investigator
head-on with all of her previous focus
and positivity
the only difference being that she was
minus a few appendages
her reputation with the force had earned
her a lot of good publicity
and so not long after her recovery she
was approached by kali
with the opportunity to join nighthaven
kylie must have been following her
career in the background and brought to
the table with her offer
unlimited access to a number of
cutting-edge prosthetics
and access to this high-end tech seems
to be a highly likely factor
in a rooney's decision to join
nighthaven
her affiliation with them appears to be
one of convenience
she's a valuable addition to the program
and between her keen senses
and deductive capabilities she makes one
hell of an operator
eventually a rooney in thermite finally
managed to meet up and a lot of
thermite's guilt was put to rest
he began to understand that she'd never
blamed him or held any animosity towards
him
she just had a number of things going on
and she was focusing on these
along with her recovery soon they were
back to a comfortable banter between
them
and it was almost like the bangkok
incident had never happened
aruni is not one to dwell in the past
she's focused on the future
moving forward and making the world a
safer place
she lives a very minimalist life which
affords her the opportunity to donate
funds
along with her time to causes she feels
particularly passionate about
the main focus of a humanitarian works
is helping with the disposal of
unexploded devices along the thai
cambodian border
and it should come as no surprise
especially because of how a little
sister died
that she is also a huge contributor to a
number of charities in regards to
helping fund their medical treatment
costs
as a rooney says in every conflict it's
the children who are made to suffer
even after the fighting is stopped
a skill she developed as a private
detective she is an exceptional
photographer
the images she shows help raise global
awareness of the vast minefields still
present even today
and the devastation to their unfortunate
victims
hero one of rooney's closest friends is
a trained
giant pouched rat they are often
together and he seems to have the
ability to provide her with comfort
and companionship like any good
emotional support animal does
a rooney is quick on her feet both
mentally and physically
her natural intuition is nearly flawless
even under the most trying of
circumstances
and she very rarely hesitates her speed
combined with her knowledge in firearms
and martial arts give her a notable edge
over her enemies
and these make her a versatile and
deadly foe
her fitness regime is insane and she
never sways from it
and this enables her to maintain peak
physical performance at all times
as harry pointed out a rooney is an
operator who's completely at home
in her own skin she moves with
effortless grace
and is as comfortable walking through a
bangkok slum as she would be
in a formal setting to see her working
is akin to watching an apex predator
in a natural environment afraid of
nothing
and master of all she sees
by now you can probably see why i didn't
combine both aruni and ace into one
video
i get too focused on one operator and
tend to go a little crazy
so rather than spending a while in the
first and then rushing through the
second to get the video out in a decent
time
i prefer to give myself a small break in
between so i can come back and do
justice to the second operator too
plus to be fair they come from quite
different backgrounds
geographically as well now as cliche as
it sounds please don't forget to click
the thumbs up if you enjoyed this video
it really does make a difference with
that crazy youtube algorithm thing
please don't make me go down the path of
setting up an only fan's page
i don't think that would benefit anyone
unless you're into spicy dad bod pics
then
slip into my dms i guess
[Music]
okay i'll stop now thank you very much
for watching and i'll catch you in the
next one
cheers
you